hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einem neuen video heute werde
ich versuchen innerhalb von einem tag
einen backflip auf dem boden zu lernen
dieses video wird freundlicherweise von
mir unterstützt und wir wünschen euch
viel spaß mit dem video das steht schon
lange auf meiner liste ich habe gesehen
dass tommy sich auch daran versucht hat
bei mir sieht es aber ein bisschen
anders aus ich habe ein bisschen andere
ausgangssituation mit fünf habe ich
angefangen zu tun und das habe ich bis
ich 13 war ziemlich ernst genommen also
ich hatte wirklich fünfmal die woche
training oder so und ich konnte zu
diesem zeitpunkt einen rückwärtssalto
jetzt sind acht jahre später ich
verbringe momentan meine zeit zehn
stunden lang am schreibtisch ich mache
kein sport und habe schon lange keinen
weg mehr einfach so auf den boden
gemacht und traue mir das auch gar nicht
mehr zu deswegen will ich herausfinden
ob das innerhalb von einem tag training
wieder möglich sein kann bevor ich unter
jungs in die halle gefahren sind haben
uns alle auf corona testen lassen ihr
seht gerade wie ich mir dieses ding in
die nase schiebe der betrieb in der
halle ist eingestellt aber für dieses
video haben eine ausnahme gemacht weil
wir uns eben alle auf grüner getestet
haben also kein stress alles ist auf die
eigentliche frage die ich aber
beantworten will ist wie lang
funktioniert so marcel memory also
profitiere ich jetzt immer noch von der
zeit vom turnen oder staatlich quasi
komplett bei null
um das herauszufinden und um das nicht
alles komplett falsch zu machen habe ich
mich mit den jungs zusammen getan mit
denen ich damals schon gewöhnt habe die
haben weiter getrennt als ich aufgehört
habe und turnen mittlerweile in der
ersten bundesliga ganz oben mit
gestartet bin ich natürlich damit mich
warm zu machen und mich zu denen um
einfach das verletzungsrisiko zu
minimieren und so viel bewegungsfreiraum
zu haben wie es nur geht wenn man so
nach hinten reist dann ist natürlich
super feld roth vorne auf dem bauch
bereich und bauchmuskel bereich da muss
man sich auf jeden fall gut dehnen und
die habe ich direkt gemerkt dass es
nicht mehr so ist wie früher
ok schön und gut aber worauf muss ich
achten wie sieht so ein rückwärtssalto
aus und was sollte ich vielleicht nicht
tun damit das ganze klappt nur damit man
so ein anhaltspunkt hat wie es aussehen
könnte ja gut ist könnte bisschen
schwierig in den so zu machen gibt es
irgendwas worauf ich worauf ich achten
sollte wenn ich jetzt statt bei dem
element sehr nah kommt vor allem darauf
an dass sobald springs ab nicht dass du
nach hin und springt oder im kaufhaus zu
ziehen
dann muss schon versuchen hoch zu
springen und eine hüfte nach vorne zu
bringen weil dann brauchst du eine
gewisse vorspannung ja und kannst daraus
dann deine beine ziehen kommt dadurch
dann
eine rotation haben wir dass da hinten
springe verliere ich höhe wenn ich zu
sehr hohen und hüfte nicht zu sehr dann
drehe ich zu lange bevor ich aber zeige
was die jungs die mir alles erklären
drauf haben und was die so können möchte
ich ganz kurz schauen wie für die
unterstützung dieses videos dann die
haben vor ein paar tagen ihr brandneues
handy vorgestellt das schaue mir admin 9
t das bestückt ist mit features die man
sonst nur aus handys kennt die über 1000
euro oder so kosten über 48 megapixel
kamera riesigen bildschirm und vor allem
5g was in der preiskategorie eigentlich
gar nicht zu finden ist bringt das handy
wirklich alles mit was ein top
smartphone braucht ich habe das ganze
mal getestet das handy ein paar tage mit
gehabt um einfach zu checken wie gut das
wirklich ist und dabei habe ich auch die
download und upload streets getestet und
selbst bei der turnhalle dass also das
ist nicht mal in köln dass es weiter
entfernt hatte ich richtig krasse
download und upload speeds die ich mit
meinem handy das sich vor weniger als
zwölf monaten für 1000 euro gekauft habe
nicht erzielen kann also es ist wirklich
verrückt checkt den link in der video
beschreibung ab wenn ihr ein neues
smartphone sucht oder neue smartphone in
der zukunft suchen dann denkt auf jeden
fall anschauen über den ersten link in
der video beschreibung könnt ihr das
handy finden check das aus ich danke
vielmals dass sie mich an dieses projekt
hier unterstützen
und jetzt zeige ich euch was die jungs
draufhaben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ganz kurz ich habe aus irgendeinem
grund die idee gehabt dass ich schneller
als max eine million hendl max hat
850.000 abonnenten also es ist ein sehr
sehr langer weg ein sehr langer prozess
wenn nämlich aber dabei unterstützen
wollt dann lasst mir gerne ein abo das
wirkt er verrückt aber ich hatte gerade
diesen geistesblitz also helft mir dabei
dass ich schneller als max die eine
million autos haben eine der größten
hürden die man zu überwinden hat wenn
man den rückwärtssalto lernen will ist
es gerade rückwärts über den kopf zu
drehen das ist und bleibt einfach eine
unnatürliche bewegung die man so im
alltag nicht finde ich habe damit
angefangen einfach rückwärts rollen auf
dem boden zu trainieren zumindest das
habe ich nicht verlernt bevor ich jetzt
anfange ihr irgendwas in irgendeiner
richtung über den kopf zu drehen und
dabei abzuspringen mache ich das alles
allein wirklich komplett ausgebucht war
ich das als allererstes nur als als
rolle über diesem block um ein gefühl
dafür zu bekommen aber ich glaube
eigentlich das ist kein problem
diese bewegung wenn man die bewegung
einmal über den kopf drin hat und sich
das einmal getraut hat dann verliert man
das nicht mehr so genau er versucht die
vor allem die hände hätte er nicht nicht
auf den boden zu setzen sondern versucht
wirklich so mit schwung mitzugehen hast
du mit den beinen aber ich stütze ich
kann ja auch nicht aus der gosse hand
raus stützen das macht ja beim salz auch
genau das macht mir auf jeden fall mut
gleichen seite auf dem boden zu machen
wenn es so will
und dann wird es auch schon direkt ernst
ich bin direkt aufs trampolin gegangen
und wollte den da machen als allererstes
habe ich da aber auch angefangen die
rückwärtsrolle erstmal auf dem trampolin
zu machen und quasi in die
rückwärtsrolle zu springen also
abzuspringen nach hinten und dann
komplett drüber
das wird sich auf jeden fall so an als
wären noch irgendetwas da was
direkt danach habe ich dann aber auch
schon den salto gemacht also es war
jetzt kein riesenproblem für mich ich
habe da wahrscheinlich auch noch davon
profitiert dass sich im altern auch nach
dem turnen immer kumpels hatte den
trampolin im garten haben wo ich sehr
sehr viel zeit verbracht hat und einfach
sicherheit rein zu bekommen habe ich
dann angefangen super super viele seite
zu machen und zwar wirklich
anstrengender als gedacht ich glaube ich
mache noch einmal springen so ganz
normal und dann probiere ich immer mit
weniger schwung vielleicht auch schon
den wirklich zu machen also wirklich
wirklich zu hocken
ich werde nicht gestreckt
ein bisschen wackelig aber das ist das
grundgefühl das neue ab da gab es dann
aber auch keinen weg mehr zurück und ich
musste mich step für step steigern bzw
eigentlich weniger gehen also weniger
unterstützung von geräten bekommen und
deswegen bin ich auf ein trampolin mit
matte gegangen dass deutlich weniger
fehler deshalb leicht umgehen wenn du
dann von ihrem schwung holt kannst du
zweimal
ich konnte mich in der bewegung
natürlich nicht selber beobachten und
deswegen habe ich die jungs dann auch
mal gefragt ob man merkt dass ich mal
geturnt habe oder ob ich mich verhalte
wie jeder andere der das ausprobieren
würdet ihr sagen dass man merkt dass ich
das schon mal gemacht hat sieht man
schon stehen dann immer so da machen
also und müssen einfach nicht mal die
anfangen sollen
dann kommt irgendwann so nah und sprung
oder sony hat gar nichts richtig machen
ja auch irgendwie schlimm wenn ich
nichts mitgenommen hätte aus der zeit
wie lange es halt passiert immer ein
bisschen
das fühlt sich so an als könnte es ja
das stimmt
im blog aber es ist jeder halten muss
noch ein bisschen weniger sehr weit nach
hinten wieder
also ist es real trug ist viel
anstrengender als ich sie in erinnerung
hatte es wird langsam bin ich schon
wirklich aus der puste
gerade hat man ein bisschen gemerkt dass
du beim ziehen schon zu sehr ein
bisschen nach hinten ist also das über
die ich abwarten bis wir den schwung
mitnehmen zum 20 weil sonst ist halt und
wird nach hinten und dann ziehst du
merkst auf einmal ob er trotzdem ich
nein aber auch hier nach ein paar
minuten einfinden und ein paar versuchen
mit hilfestellung kein problem weil der
sprung einfach wirklich immer noch aus
dem gerät kommt nicht aus dem bein das
sollte sich dann aber im nächsten
versuch ändern ich bin von einer sehr
hohen auf eine niedrigere matte
gesprungen um einfach ein bisschen mehr
zeit zu haben und trotzdem für
sicherheit zu sorgen obwohl ich zu dem
zeitpunkt schon relativ sicher war dass
ich das schaffen kann hat sich das auf
der matte nochmal deutlich anders
angefühlt also wirklich weil einfach
weniger schwung da ist und es wirklich
darauf ankommt was man selber mit seinem
körper macht ich habe mich dann immer
eine zeit lang gesammelt und wirklich
meinen kompletten fokus auf diesen einen
sprung gesetzt um die komplette kraft
für den sprung zu haben das schlimmste
was passieren kann ist dass man
irgendwie in gedanken ist und einfach so
vor sich hin springt weil dann wird's
gefährlich
da schon anders an wenn nicht in der
logik dass ich mir jetzt auch mit der
bewährten die bewegung durchziehen
also ich muss drinnen bleiben wenn ich
mich genau also das ist halt so wenn du
jetzt in der luft irgendwie dich
entscheidest auf einmal die panzer in
der luft nichts mehr ändern
nun war kannst du ihn daher liegen die
rausgehen versuchten sonst aber diese
bewegung abzubrechen wird nicht
funktionieren
hat sich ein paar atmen dann haben wir
uns immer weiter gesteigert und den
abstand zwischen den matten immer
verringert ich habe mich zu dem
zeitpunkt wirklich schon sicher gefühlt
einfach weil ich zu dem zeitpunkt schon
300 drehungen über dem kopf gemacht
hatte also rollen rollen auf dem
trampolin trampolin anderes trampolin
auf dem sprungbrett also da hatte ich
wirklich schon mehrere stunden lang
dafür trainiert auch das hat nach ein
paar versuchen mit hilfestellung
geklappt ich hatte irgendwie das gefühl
dass auch wenn der abstand geringer wird
man einfach automatisch mehr kraft rein
steckt und das hat mir daniel auch
bestätigt wenn wir springen am boden und
element in die grube machen und seine
matte reinlegen du kommst immer gerade
so im normalfall richtig auch wenn du
halt höher machst du kommst trotzdem
irgendwie wieder hast du kannst dich
halt einfach mit der höhe also deckt
körper oder der kopf macht das in
irgendeiner weise automatisch und dann
wird ziemlich schnell ziemlich ernst nur
auf dem boden mit kleiner matte ohne
erhöhung zum glück hatte ich jemanden
dabei der mehr hilfestellung geben
konnte ein ausgebildeter trainer
und da es nach hier darf er jetzt schon
deutlich
perfekt ist das natürlich noch mal so
wenn ihr zuhause das gerne machen wollt
dann würde ich euch dringend davon
abraten sagen wir 70 kilo springt meter
hoch und landet mit 70 kilo aus einem
meter auf dem nacken das ist schon
wirklich wirklich unangenehm und kann
sehr gefährlich werden also macht das
einfach nicht oder macht das nur mit
hilfestellungen von leuten die es
wirklich können aber alles ganz normal
wie eben einfach nur ein bisschen mehr
dampf beim absprung
den rest komplett gleich das war es
schon
also wenn die sich nicht trauen sie
heute ja ich hab das gefühl man traut
sich dreimal und beim vierten mal denkt
man so ja es gab ja sogar was der jetzt
könnt ihr euch auf den kopf
ich habe hier noch mal die 55 zentimeter
hier gezogen
das schon sehr sehr nice das macht echt
laune ohne mathe auf dem boden habe ich
mich dann viel sicherer gefühlt einfach
weil ich einen festen stand hatte weil
das im boden war von dem ich besser
abspringen konnte und wo die matte
nämlich kraft geraubt hat beim abstieg
ohne andy der dann aber hätte eingreifen
können hat sich das nochmal komplett
anders angefühlt ich habe mich wirklich
komplett darauf fokussiert meine
komplette kraft jetzt in diesen einen
sprung zu setzen und dann
geil alter hätte ich den job nicht
mitgerechnet und ohne scheiß ich war
wirklich überrascht dass es geklappt hat
ich habe wirklich ja überhaupt keinen
sport gemacht und trotzdem habe ich so
viel noch von dieser zeit profitiert
also vielleicht an meine eltern nehme
ich damals zum kunst- und geschleppt
haben ich bin wirklich sehr happy mit
dem ausgang und das hat mir eine menge
spaß gemacht das war es mit diesem video
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
damit wir möglichst schnell zu einer
million kommen und damit kein video mehr
verpasst macht's gut